political leaders in New York in
Virginia are touting the benefits of
Amazon's historic expansion in their
states you're looking at pictures of the
New York site in Long Island City after
a 13-month search and bids from 238
cities the tech giant announced it will
split it
second headquarters between the Long
Island City neighborhood in Queens New
York and Arlington Virginia Amazon hopes
to bring 25,000 jobs and two and a half
billion dollars of investment to each
location the company was offered more
than two billion dollars in tax
incentives from the two combined in a
new york new article the Atlantic's
Derek Thompson asks why are US cities
spending tens of billions of dollars to
steal jobs from one another in the first
place Derek is with us now
good morning good morning what do we
want governor's mayor's others to say
and put out the red carpet and bring a
company like Amazon to their
neighborhood
sure Amazon's a fantastic company and
it's a credit to many cities that get
Amazon jobs or jobs from Apple or any
other large company but here's the issue
every year the National we spend as
cities and states seventy to ninety
billion dollars just to move jobs within
the US just steal jobs essentially from
other US cities and states that's more
than the federal government spends on
housing or infrastructure and this is
money that is taken from from cash that
would be spent on streets on roads on
bridges on broken subway systems like
right here in New York on schools on
municipal funds that should go to the
people but instead go to companies that
can be worth trillions of dollars okay
Amazon sells in Long Island City and New
York that then creates tax revenue sales
tax absolutely it's a great question
this the experience though of lots of
cities like let's say I'm going to use
examples from Wisconsin and wood and
Washington suggests that a lot of times
companies promise to deliver on these
count on these subsidies but actually
don't
so Foxconn for example the Chinese
manufacturer received a four billion
dollar subsidy from Wisconsin to build a
factory there they've now said they're
not going to create 13,000 jobs is
initially promised but rather 10,000
jobs and oh by the way that factory they
were going to build they might not build
and if they do it's gonna be filled with
robots but Germans had a really similar
experience in Washington eight billion
dollar subsidy for bone
if they're now trying to claw back
because they haven't created as many
jobs as promised so yes these are great
companies but they don't always follow
through with the prompts some of these
incentives are tied to jobs unlike what
we saw in Foxconn right so could you say
lesson learned that this is a really
interesting point because you're right
if you're just going to subsidize the
jobs are created what's the problem well
here's the problem
Amazon is a retail advertising and media
conglomerate and it is being paid 1.6
billion dollars to move to the nation's
capital of retail advertising and media
that seems like 1.6 billion dollars to
pay Amazon to do something they were
probably going to do anyway which is
move many thousand jobs maybe not twenty
five thousand but many thousands and
thousands of jobs to New York City the
nation's capital of business so in many
ways you see these corporate subsidies
go to pay companies to do that which
they were going to do anyway and that is
wasteful spending especially when it's
taking one to one one for one from money
that would go to roads bridges and
education I don't know if they were
gonna do that number one but number two
Derek sounds like you're drinking a
little glass of haterade
why should Amazon be blamed because some
could say listen this is just a smart
business decision on their part isn't it
up to the cities the cities don't have
to make the bid if they want to if they
want to fix a crappy subway system they
should do that why is Amazon being
blamed because they're taking advantage
of a good business decision you're
exactly right if I'm serving the hater I
don't want to I don't I'm not serving
the hater a to Amazon I'm not even maybe
serving the hater rates in New York City
or New York State I'd like to sir this
hater rate to the federal government
because there is a clause in the US
Constitution that says the US government
has the ability to monitor interstate
commerce to make laws regarding that and
if we are essentially in a situation
where states are spending ninety billion
dollars every year just moving jobs
across state lines the federal
government can make a decision that says
maybe let's ban this maybe let's say
that these states and cities can't spend
any money at all on companies they
should spend monies on making their
cities better on improving
infrastructure and workforce and
education those cities to create cities
that companies want to go to anyway well
I said Amazon can't be blamed for that
no are you upset about the cities that
were chosen I do think that to a certain
extent Amazon dramatized
as if it was going to be some sort of
Cinderella ball where they were going to
put the slipper on a surprising city's
proverbial foot and instead it's sort of
like they slip the the slipper onto you
know the evil stepsister Anastasia I
mean not to denigrate New York City but
we don't need an Amazon to be the
greatest you know business city in
America what about the information that
Amazon acquired in terms of all the bids
from these cities yeah I think I think
this is a fascinating case we don't
really know yet what information they
got from each city is but it's clearly
the case that a city with national
ambitions that's trying to build
warehouses and offices around the
country around the world really gain a
lot of knowledge by essentially enticing
these cities to tell them what their
infrastructure plans on so look a
brilliant brilliant move by Jeff Bezos
who's a genius but I would like to see
this system the rules of the system fit
in a third smaller city in Nashville we
should point out Indy great to have you
on thank you so much you don't drink so
much haterade is raising good question
yes yeah great conversation thank you
[Music]